معكم الان هذه الصور كذلك التي وردتني في
حلقه الهلا عن الرعب والخوف
للسودانيين المتواجدين في مطار الخرطوم
الدولي جراء الاشتباكات والمواجهات
العنيفه التي شهدها ربما المطار خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه بالاضافه الى عده
مناطق اخرى في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
في محيط القصر الرئاسي
وكذلك بعض الانباء التي تتحدث عن السيطره
من قبل القوات الدعم السريع كما نشرت ذلك
رويترز للقصر الرئاسي لمنزل عبد الفتاح
البرهان
ونفي من قبل الجيش الباكس عفوا الجيش
السوداني لكل هذه المعلومات
اذا هذه الصور كما نشاهد الان
لسودانيين
وهم يعيشون حاله من الرعب والهلع والخوف
جراء هذه المواجهات والاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات